hello already gone already gone okay
hello I'm Alison rich today we will be
okay
our story begins in England it's 9:45
p.m. December 3rd 1926 famed mystery
writer Agatha Christie she's kind of
like the Stephen King of in the 1920s
packed a small suitcase walks out of her
house and she dismissed eree so next day
my name George best is walking along and
then he comes to the bottom of the hill
and he's like whoa what's this car doing
your cars don't aren't at the bottom of
hills and the car as the hood popped and
a door is open and the lights are on
so he calls the police the police common
Deputy Chief Constable William Kenward
was like you know what I'm on the case
and I'm gonna search the share of this
and he looks inside just an expired
license and a piece of paper and they
say Agatha Christie it's got vocal fry'
so he's like oh my god this been a
mystery with our own mystery writer
so then William Kenward is like I'm
gonna get scouts I'm gonna get
bloodhounds how many divers I'm gonna
get planes we've never used plans before
to search for someone but you don't know
what if we can do it well they've
can't were searching like to the Meccans
but no dice they don't find a so
Kendra it's like okay what I'm gonna do
is we're gonna love a mystery I'm gonna
get to mystery writers to help find her
so he employs the help of Sir Arthur
Conan Doyle aka the writer of Sherlock
Holmes and then this lady Dorothy L
sayers who we don't know somebody comes
in like record scratch oh what don't
worry about it we found a Geetha so
eleven days after she disappeared people
are waiting being like what happened to
same mystery writer Agatha Christie
where did she go and she's like I don't
know I can't I can't help you the police
are like what really disappointing we're
all searching for her but she's just
here um so the police were left to just
like piece together what had happened
over those eleven days so flashback okay
at the time December 3rd 1926 um Agatha
is having a tough time
okay she's 36 and life is he punched her
in the tits okay like her marriage is on
the rocks and her husband Archie's being
a dick about it he was like I want to
marry my secretary but I'm already
married
miss gay wife of mine so she starts to
exhibit the signs of a nervous breakdown
and Archie's I cam and I leave you I'm
gonna leave you for my secretary because
I like her better than you and she's
like wow really cool she's like you know
what I'm gonna go too I'm gonna leave
I'm gonna drive to London so she starts
driving to London
car except she gets into a cars so 24
hours later very mysteriously she
arrives at this spa and hotel called the
Swan hydro Pathak in Harrogate 230 miles
from where she had been she checks in
and she's like hey look at me I'm
wearing glasses I wasn't wearing glasses
before and I'm a different hairstyle why
did she staged her own disappearance or
did she have a mental break right and
she's like my name is Teresa Neely I'm
from Cape Town South Africa I just lost
a child please lay off my back I'm
trying to recuperate that's all there is
to it and no tell people like okay too
much information and then she's like you
know what I don't have a great time and
you know like live it up
she gets some beauty treatment she goes
dancing chillin out maxin relaxin all
cool and she's reading her own story
like ooh what's going on in the news
this is interesting the weather's gonna
be 78 and there's a lady who's missing
an Agatha Christie so be careful with
that drink so meanwhile a chambermaid is
like wait aren't you aren't you this
person and she's just like I don't know
what you're saying
so this really bother me I'm gonna fall
okay I got it
so the police baton know what to make of
it they're like there's like she's in a
car crash so she in amnesia but so I
guess it's like I don't know you know
what but what I do know is I have a new
attitude I divorce my husband and I'm
gonna go on to write 80 novels and 66
are gonna be mystery novels and I'm
gonna be such a best-selling author that
the only person who meets me or
literature that beats me is the bible
and shakespeare
exactly what she did she was a huge
success she never speaks of the event
again Oh PS I forgot to say that at one
point
Agatha said to her sister I can
disappear at any point if I wanted to I
don't know how to do it I don't know all
the stuff because I know mysteries so I
just beat her maybe I know how to do it
okay great I feel like I could say my
I'm Alison rich Navy sailor yeah
hello I'm Alison
[Music]
you